jump center against adebayo and this is
going to be a very fun matchup at center
two contrasting styles two really
talented players mark jackson at the
center position but the thing that makes
it interesting two very
highly skilled centers that have
tremendous versatility and set the tone
for their teams
so jimmy butler going over to the heat
bench
with the delay butler had on a jersey
that did not have
a name on it and that was something he
wanted to do and get approval from the
league
now he's putting on the jersey that
requires a name
oh so he had to change his jersey right
there
that's my guess well because that jersey
had nothing on it so
everybody has to have something on their
jersey okay
either their name or wanted a chosen one
that was a great could you remember just
before the opening tip jimmy butler came
out on the floor with a jersey that had
no name on the back
not butler's last name no social justice
message
now the league denied his request to
play the game
with nothing on his back so after he
came out with the nameless jersey
he went back to the bench and put on
what he's wearing now it was his way of
making a statement about social
injustice
butler told me he wanted no name on his
back because he doesn't want to be
treated differently
because he's jimmy butler the basketball
player that everyone knows he said i'm
like every other proud african-american
male
my message is i'm that no-name black guy
like everyone else
whose story might not get told if
something were to happen to me
mike